[Musique]
et l'on retrouve encore monsieur chaban
delmas dans d'autres secteurs de
l'actualité le premier ministre
l'habitude depuis quelques mois
d'évoquer souvent ce problème il s'agit
de l'habitat insalubre
autrement dit des bidonvilles le point
avec christian guy pour les bidonvilles
nous allons doubler l'action qui
s'appuie depuis 1964 sur la loi debré
doublé l'action de telle manière que au
plus tard en 1972 il n'y est plus du
tout de bidonvilles ni dans la région
parisienne ni en france
ce pari le premier ministre l'a lancé il
y a dix huit mois il en reste 16 pour le
tenir ce sera difficile car entre
février 1970 septembre 1971
un tiers seulement de ces bidonvilles
ont disparu certaines opérations comme à
nanterre ont été menées de façon
spectaculaire mais il reste paris toulon
le havre lille et plus près de nous
aubervilliers en se donnant trois ans
monsieur chaban delmas avec un bulldozer
et de la bonne volonté ne suffisent pas
pour supprimer l'insupportable d'abord
coordonnées des actions à l'échelon
financier le polémiste a quintuplé les
crédits question crédit pas là messieurs
les préfets des moyens juridiques très
sévère il fallait toucher à ce sacré
droit de propriété
problème juridique financier problèmes
administratifs
mais le plus souvent aussi problèmes
sociaux il n'est pas rare de voir 8 10
12 ans pas à la dimension de nos
appartements hlm polaire ou cités de
transit n'est pas très peu
systématiquement parmi de très nombreux
il y a également le ferai lorsque vous
ai parlé tout à l'heure du conte à mais
le bulldozer ont détruit les
travailleurs migrants qui est habitué à
rejoindre son lieu de travail un quart
de radis
pour lui le fait d'être logé à plus d'un
quart d'heure à pied par rapport à son
ancien logement est considéré comme une
déportation
avant de détruire les bidonvilles il
fallait donc s'en donner les moyens
c'est aujourd'hui chose faite de
récentes instructions adressées aux
préfets leur permettent de faire agir en
même temps et au même endroit
la police les domaines l'assistance
sociale les hlm et aussi la justice en
un mot les conditions semblent
maintenant réunies pour que soit tenu le
délai fixé par le premier ministre oui
enfin nous en avons l'assurance des
crédits supplémentaires et des
dispositions d'ordre légal permettent
maintenant que peut être sûr que dans
les trois mois celui dont ville va enfin
disparaître mais je dois vous dire que
ça solutionne pas tout le problème parce
que cet aspect très voyant va
disparaître mais les travailleurs
immigrés sont maintenant regagner
maintenant les vieux taudis et derrière
les façades
ils vivent dans une misère tout aussi
grave que celle ci ce danger est réel
900 mille personnes vivent déjà dans ces
fameux taudis où les travailleurs
étrangers s'entassent par dizaines sur
quelques mètres carrés pour le seul
profit des marchands de sommeil corps et
ont gagné alors à supprimer ce que l'on
appelle les bidonvilles horizontaux si
la misère continue à grandir
bien à l'abri derrière des murs plus de
bidonvilles constitué en vidant ville
fin 72
alors restera continuellement mais
j'espère dans un délai de quelques
années que nous en sortirons tous le
problème des taudis qui est évidemment
le gros problème à partir de 62
de ce point de vue ce département de la
seine saint denis
les francos
à saint-denis c'était il ya quatre ans
l'un des plus grands bidonvilles de la
région parisienne au printemps prochain
il sera remplacé par une pelouse et la
plupart de ses habitants iront
s'installer dans les hlm d'en face oui
c'est vrai en france dans moins de deux
ans les grands bidonvilles auront
disparu mais trente cinq mille personnes
vivent encore aujourd'hui dans le carton
et la tôle ondulée
mais un million de noirs de portugais
d'algériens et de français vivent encore
dans des taudis
c'est la misère crasse des banlieues et
des vieux quartiers que révèle de temps
à autre la pioche des démolisseurs
depuis quelques années on ne se contente
plus de casser les bidonvilles de casser
les taudis pour chasser cette misère
ailleurs en trois ans le montant des
crédits de l'état pour la résorption de
l'habitat insalubre a été multipliée par
six cette année 125 millions et en trois
ans le nombre des logements des cités de
transit et des foyers de travailleurs
n'a cessé de croître
mais aujourd'hui si l'on possède
l'argent les crédits nécessaires
on doit faire face à un problème qui
devient inquiétant celui des terrains en
ville la place coûte cher de plus en
plus cher et les municipalités ne cède
pas volontiers leur terrain pour loger
des noirs ou des portugais loger des
immigrés c'est très bien dit en mai elle
est plutôt construire chez le maire
voisin et c'est pourquoi ils auront
peut-être demain logement décent mais un
logement qu'ils devront quitter plus tôt
que les autres pour se rendre sur le
chantier
[Musique]
bidonville taudis chambres dortoirs des
immigrés pourtant connaissent un
meilleur sort
les foyers financée par le gouvernement
abritait fin 72 126 milles célibataire
l'état avait dépensé en 1968 240
millions de francs de francs l'ours en
temps pour offrir des logements aux
travailleurs venus en france avec leurs
femmes et leurs enfants
quatre ans plus tard il dépensait quatre
fois plus les familles d'immigrés ont
jusqu'à un certain point accès aux hlm
les familles françaises comme il se doit
passant d'abord à quoi il faut ajouter
qu'en dehors des hlm
quinze mille huit cents ou veillée
suivie de leur famille ont été logés par
les pouvoirs publics dans des
appartements construits pour eux de 1959
à 1972
quinze mille huit cents logements donc
en 13 ans
[Musique]